la retaliación rusa fue masiva la mayor
oleada de ataques aéreos contra lugares
alejados de la línea de batalla Desde
los primeros días de la guerra
bombardeos que llegan tras el atentado
contra el puente de crimea del que
Vladimir Putin acusado Ucrania
denunciando actos terroristas
en la mañana de hoy tal como sugirió el
Ministerio de defensa y de acuerdo con
el plan elaborado por el Estado Mayor
ruso se lanzó un ataque masivo con armas
de largo alcance y alta precisión desde
el aire el mar y la tierra contra la
infraestructura energética te mando
militar y de comunicaciones de ucranias
desde el inicio de la guerra Rusia llega
a atacar civiles sin embargo la
evidencia demuestra lo contrario se
repartaron varios muertos en la capital
kiev donde los misiles alcanzaron el
centro de la ciudad como el patio de
recreo de este parque
esta mañana han muerto cinco personas 42
están hospitalizadas
algunas en estado crítico por lo que la
cifra de Muertos podría aumentar
los misiles alcanzaron viviendas así
como una universidad Bueno después
detrás de mí se puede ver uno de los
edificios de la Universidad Nacional de
construcción naval que fue alcanzado por
un misil una vez más Y de nuevo fue un
misil s-300
se registraron explosiones en varias
otras ciudades como Live saporiya
harkkive Pro en esta última al menos
cuatro muertos según las autoridades
regionales los ataques rusos cayeron
cerca a un bus y afectaron zonas
residenciales no hay objetivos militares
aquí no esperábamos ataques aquí es
aterrador la embestida rusa sí
perjudicular eléctrica ucraniana
obligando al gobierno a pedirle a los
ciudadanos a reducir el consumo de
energía entre las 5 de la tarde y las 10
de la noche y a detener las
exportaciones de energía al resto Europa
elevando las preocupaciones locales
sobre los posibles cortes eléctricos de
cara al invierno